-Here's how the game works.
Shaq and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
Could be people,
objects, anything.
We have 45 seconds
to try to get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want
or use gestures.
You just can't say
any of the words on the card.
Shaq, you will be
guessing first.
Let's get into position.
[ Laughter ]
Is the room really spinning?
-Yeah.
-Okay, good. Perfect.
All right. Ready, buddy?
Uh, here we go.
Okay. Open the curtain.
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Okay.
President. Stovepipe hat.
-Abraham Lincoln.
-Yeah.
Mike Myers.
The voice of this cartoon movie.
He's a monster. He's green.
-SpongeBob SquarePants.
-No. Green.
Like a troll type of thing.
Like an ogre.
Cartoon.
There was like four of them.
-Oh. Shrek.
-Yeah.
And, then, it's a beverage --
[ Buzzer ]
Gosh!
Can we see what it is?
-Come on, Jimmy!
-Sorry about that.
I got to go faster.
You almost got it.
Abraham Lincoln...
[ Laughter ]
...and Shrek sharing
a milkshake.
And that's probably what it was.
I was going to say milkshake.
Sorry I didn't get to it.
All right. Here we go.
You can close the curtain now.
Now it's my turn.
It's my turn to guess.
I'm going to do this. All right.
Shaq, grab the card.
And open the curtain
when you can.
[ Laughter ]
-You see them in New York.
-The Knicks.
-They're not rats,
but they have long tails also.
-Pigeons?
-They're in parks.
-Pigeons. Squirrel.
-Yes.
Black guys don't use it, but
white guys use it at the beach.
-Sunscreen?
-Yes.
-Wah! Wah!
-Baby.
-Yes. Put them all together.
-Oh, yeah. What was it again?
A baby wearing sunscreen --
-The little animal.
-A squirrel is putting
sunscreen on a baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me see that.
Wow! Oh, wow!
That's unbelievable.
That is unbelievable.
Wow. Well, they're buddies.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know. All right.
Here we go. All right.
-You use sunblock?
-Some things just -- Yeah, I do.
-I never use sunblock.
-You don't use it, yeah, no.
Did not know that.
-We don't need it, right, Quest?
We don't need that.
-Nah.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Here we go.
Open the curtain.
[ Laughter ]
All right. She's --
-Statue of Liberty.
-Yes.
When you celebrate in a
football game in the end zone.
-Touchdown.
-You do a --
-Dance. Celebration.
-If you're the greatest of all
time, you're also called...
-The GOAT.
-Yeah. Put them together.
-Statue of Liberty
celebrating with a goat.
-Yes! That's correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow. At one point,
the Statue of Liberty
was flossing at one point.
Doing a little floss.
There you go. Not bad.
That's pretty cool.
That's fantastic.
All right. Here we go.
Please close the curtain.
Thank you. The referee
looked a little disturbed.
-He did.
-All right. Here we go.
It's the last one right here.
-Last one?
-This is for all the money.
Do you do that?
High-fiving when you do that?
Do you do that, like,
with your teammates and stuff?
-Only with my closest friends.
[ Audience awws ]
-I love you, dude.
-Love you, too, brother.
-What's your nickname for me?
Do you remember?
-Boy Boy.
[ Laughter ]
-Boy Boy. All right.
-Yeah.
-Let's see what's
behind me right now.
[ Laughs ] Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-He has a flat head like
Charles Barkley, and he's green.
[ Laughter ]
And he has that thing --
-Frankenstein.
-Yes. Boing. When you jump.
-Jumping on -- Trampoline.
-Yep.
[ Humming ]
-Lollipop.
-Yes. Put them all together.
-Frankenstein
licking a lollipop,
jumping on a trampoline?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
That is just bizarre stuff.
Shaquille O'Neal, everybody.
-Thank you.